[Music]
welcome back in the minutes following
news of the verdict both johnny depp and
amber heard took to social media
releasing individual statements about
the trial's outcome
for his part johnny depp said the jury
gave him his life back his statement
reads in part quote false very serious
criminal allegations were levied at me
via the media which triggered an endless
barrage of hateful content although no
charges were ever brought against me it
had already traveled around the world
twice within a nanosecond and it had a
seismic impact on my life and my career
and six years later the jury gave me my
life back i am truly humbled
heard also released a statement saying
she is heartbroken with the outcome her
statement reads in part quote the
disappointment i feel today is beyond
words i am even more disappointed with
what this verdict means for other women
it is a setback it sets back the clock
to a time when a woman who spoke up and
spoke out could be publicly shamed and
humiliated it sets back the idea that
violence against women is to be taken
seriously
terry do you believe depp has his life
back as he said after this trial or is
there more work he needs to do before we
see him back on the big screen again
oh i think this trial and definitely the
verdict has given him his life back even
if he hadn't won i think just telling
his story meant a lot but he did win and
on every one of those statements so i
think he has his reputation back and
reputation is important it takes years
and years to build a reputation and it
takes seconds to break it down and we
saw with the statements that amber heard
made in the washington post in december
of 2018
that she in fact did cause harm to his
reputation and so i think he needed to
do what he did people questioned why he
brought this suit that was the very
first question that he was asked by
camille vasquez on direct examination
examination and he said i brought it
because my reputation is very important
yeah i mean hey
i'll go on the record
i was wrong i thought this was a foolish
lawsuit to bring up i thought everyone's
gonna lose here airing out your dirty
laundry
but don't tell my wife i'm saying this
but i can be wrong sometimes and i guess
i was here tracy
heard worries about sexual assault
claims in the future do you share her
worries
no and i am offended by by the statement
um it's based on this biased belief on
stereotypes of women that only women can
be victims and i have to tell you i i'm
offended because
what about non-binary individuals or
what about trans people
specifically when it comes to non-binary
26 of california high schoolers in 2018
identified as non-binary so what what
are they to do where do they fit in on
this yeah it was interesting i know many
other people kind of highlight as well
because johnny depp had made a point
that men and women can be victims of
domestic violence something that i think
many people kind of heard as a whisper
about men being victims and now is more
established here and amber heard came
out specifically about women and i think
the juxtaposition between the two uh
kind of lend itself to to show why maybe
johnny depp won this case the end of the
day but thank you for that point when we
come back the lawn crime network's
founder dan abram gives his take on the
johnny depp amber heard verdict why he
calls the verdict a total loss for amber
hurt
you